اردوغان قال ايضا خلال زياره تفقديه
لمدينه غازي عنتاب جنوب تركيا ان بناء
منازل للمتضررين هو اولويه الدوله كما اكد
الرئيس التركي ان تم تاجهات لم يسميها
تحاول استغلال الاحداث في البلاد
للحصول على مكاسب سياسيه
كما ترون فان اعمال رفع الانقاض ما زالت
مستمره فمنذ اللحظه الاولى للزلزال تعمل
كل مؤسسات الدوله بقوه على الارض هدفنا ان
نبني منازل لجميع المواطنين المتضررين في
المحافظات العشر خلال عام بالاضافه الى
تعويضهم عن ممتلكاتهم وذلك عقب منح كل
عائله متضرره مبلغ عشره الاف ليره في
المرحله الاولى املا في تخفيف بعض الامهم
هذا وقد اقر البرلمان التركي باغلبيه
الاصوات مشروع قانون للرئيس التركي باعلام
حاله الطوارئ ثلاثه اشهر في عشر محافظات
تركيه في منطقه زلزال ويشمل القانون
محافظات كهرمان مارش وغازي عنتاب وعثمانيه
وديار بكر وملاطيا وارفاهتاي وكليس واضنه
وفي حين صوت نواب حزب العداله والتنميه
وحزب الحركه القوميه لصالح التشريع اعترض
عليه نواب حزب الشعب الجمهوري وحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه والحزب الصالح بدعوه انه يزيد
من صلاحياته رئيس الجمهوريه وانه سيحد من
الحقوق والحريات
من جانبيه قال نائب رئيس التركي فؤاد
اوكتاي ان اعمال الاغاثه والمساعدات
واجهت مشاكل بسبب حاله الطقس السيئه في
اللحظات الاولى للزلزال وجاء ذلك خلال
كلمه القاها في البرلمان التركي اثناء
جلسه التصويت على تشريع اعلان حاله
الطوارئ في المحافظه المنكوبه لمده ثلاثه
اشهر
شهدت المنطقه حاله جويه سيئه للغايه وهذا
ما منعنا من ارسال المساعدات عن طريق الجو
لنتجنب سقوط طائرات مروحيه اما في مناطق
مثل نورداغ في غاز عنتاب فقد كان ايصال
المساعدات برا صعبا جدا بسبب ازمه المرور
في الطرق المؤديه اليها حاليا وصلوا
المساعدات لكل مدن المحافظات العشر
المتضرره من الزلزال